ich bin zum ersten Mal in meinem Leben
First Class mit einer der besten
Airlines der Welt geflogen und so viel
habe ich bezahlt morgens wurde ich an
meinem Hotel von einem persönlichen
Fahrer abgeholt und zum Terminal
gefahren sobald man mit Emirates
Business Class fliegt ist das Shuttle
immer inklusive dann ging es zunächst in
die Emirates Business und First Class
Lounge in Frankfurt am Flughafen dort
gab es Frühstück und dann ging es auch
schon los zum Boarding in einer Boeing
777 ging es für mich nach Dubai und ich
war an dem Tag tatsächlich der einzige
First Class Passagier somit hatte ich
mit Simon meinen eigenen Flugbegleiter
und der hat sich wirklich rührend um
mich gekümmert die First Class bietet
acht verschiedene kleine Zimmer mit Bett
es gibt eine umfangreiche Wein und
champagnerkarte ein tolles essensmenü
mit mehreren Gängen und einer Snackkarte
als First Class Reisender kann man den
ganzen Flug über bestellen was man will
fun fact ich habe zum ersten Mal in
meinem Leben Cavia gegessen wenn man
müde wird bauen die Flugbegleiter den
Sitz in ein Bett und Matratze um
wirklich sehr bequem außerdem gab es ein
amenity Kit im Wert von ca 150 €
geschenkt und ein Pyjama die sech
Stunden Flugzeit ging super schnell um
und ich bin besoffen und geflasht in
Dubai angekommen insgesamt habe ich für
den Hinflug 3000 € bezahlt findet ihr es
hat sich gelohnt